[Music]
hello and welcome
everyone to the webinar digital
marketing work after covid19
and this is a webinar presented by
simply learn part of our step into the
sunlight webinar series
which will continue for the next several
weeks i'm your host
stewart creek a managing marketer
at simply learn my guest today is a
thought leader
in digital marketing brad gettys a bit
more about him in a moment
brad yetis is the ppc chair at
simplylearn he's the
co-founder of ed alice's an
author and speaker the author of
advanced google adwords
co-founder of analysis which is an
automated
testing and ppc recommendations platform
his mission is to share his expertise
particularly in paid search with online
marketers to help you build
successful online campaigns frequently
writes columns for search engine land
he's keynoted
spoken at more than 125 conferences he's
led more than 100 google ads
seminars glad to have him here today
welcome back hey stewart and i'll flip
my video so you can see how
not short my hair is compared to the
picture
um i taken last year
let me uh bring up our first question
this is going to be in a question and
answer
format kind of a free-form discussion
with brad our first question is
brad how is the digital marketing field
going to evolve
as we come out of the coveted pandemic
yes so there's in in reality right
there's probably a few different
ways we're seeing this the first
is the the pure speed of changes
um microsoft ceo satya on their last
earnings call
said that microsoft has seen two
years of digital transformation
in the past two months right now that
that goes from remote teams to
increased distance collaboration to how
marketers
are evolving with managing their
accounts so there's a huge speed
change from the their customer
standpoint right which is us marketers
um second we see
the platforms evolving as they
dramatically
shift emphasis towards what's necessary
today so when you looked at say a google
ads beforehand
right google would have their dev
scattered in in you know 20 different
projects getting things done and slowly
releasing things
and so when when covet hits roughly
depending on whose numbers and what
country looking at um
40 to 50 of all people had never
bought a product online which i it
sounds to me i was like wow that's a
crazy high number
um incredible i was i was blown away by
that right
and since kovitz happened that number is
somewhere around
25 have never bought something online so
in the last three months
a quarter of people who have never
bought something online
made their first purchase and in many
cases of course have made multiples
so it's it's pushed consumers to doing
more things online
now what that's then caused right is
you've got a lot of newer consumers out
and so
they want information
now and so real time information right
you've heard about this from like a
search results organic standpoint for a
while what's on your website
they kind of want this in the ads right
which which is very new
um if something you know things still
break so
if they break and you're searching for
hey my toilet broke and i need a plumber
does the plumber's ad say right um
contact list that we do safe wear masks
they not mention
it right those are things people want
now and i'm probably going to see some
of those trends continue
now lastly well machine learning is is
not a new concept
but machine learning relies on highly
predictable data
if data is very scattered right it's up
and down it's up and down
machine learning's never done well the
in you know it could see like oh hey
it's going to be black friday again
um i should expect increasing conversion
rates because it's seen that for
you know six years or oh christmas is
coming right it was very predictable
but covid the trend changes have been so
dramatic and so fast
that machine learning has finally gotten
the ability
to start seeing how dramatic
how quickly dramatic changes can happen
and react to it it's still not there yet
um but that's going to be a welcome
change of machine learning
starting to figure out fast changes to
data
which is a really brand new one here and
so
from an overall field industry
standpoint right we're really looking at
is speed to changes both
internally and your client base if
you're an agency right
so your clients are demanding a little
bit more if you're you know
internal focus then your clients be
consumers whoever
are pushing for things faster that more
transparency which
again is a very worldwide concept you
know the past few years is more
transparency
um and and better machine learning which
is a really good one overall so those
are probably like
at the macro level right the the bigger
things we're seeing
um when you talk about machine learning
and reacting to
the unusual what about the aspect of
artificial intelligence or of data
science in general
that looks for um outliers and
exceptions
that uh becoming a more important aspect
of
automated systems yeah it's you know
what so
outlier identification has always been
something that machines are better than
humans right this is a true outlier
that's just a little bit off the trend
but they were sort of dismissed right
because you you want the median the mean
you know the outliers you can't always
accommodate for so what machine learning
and data scientists
are starting to look at is if there's a
couple of outliers
are they outliers or are they predicting
a trend change so if you see you know
here's our our trend line going along
maybe a little bit up and then we've got
you know an outlier down here and then
we go up a little bit there's another
outlier here
is this predicting that we're about to
see a big down change we should expect
that
or are they outliers right and that's
what you know data scientists machine
learning
are still struggling with but they're
working more
on that of using outlier data to
understand
is it an outlier just hey we can't deal
with this
or is it predicting the trends in
advance
to to move that direction right because
the
the key thing that happens in these
kind of what called black swan events
the unexpected
disruptions is that what is an outlier
at uh day one of the event becomes the
new normal
later in the event maybe by week one or
by week ten
um which kind of leads into our next
question beer with me
and our next question is
what does the new normal look like so
you know what we're still learning this
in reality right like we can kind of
predict this a little bit
um one is of course
a technology adoption and so
when we went into this right and you
know we're a platform um analysis
and so we essentially had you know three
types of clients we had those who went
oh we're in travel
pause we don't know what we're doing
with what we're dealing with
and then we had those who
were incredibly organized they have had
project management in place they had
data sharing in place
they had central document repositories
in place
they they you know put their workers at
home their workers had access to
everything
they went business as usual really well
just from home which and there's a few
more trends we'll get into there
then you had those with the employees
with 8 000 things on their desktop
they might have had a project management
system or google docs but
it wasn't part of the culture they
struggled mightily and and that group
has made
the biggest change in the past three
months
of adopting to remote work
whether that is you know with they move
to you know they may not move to agile
marketing they've
moved to project management and document
collaboration and so forth
now the the second part of that event
right is when you put everyone at home
in a non you know non-traditional work
environment
is how does your boss judge them and so
this is where you had companies who
probably already had some remote workers
and
they trust their employees to just keep
working
and then you had those who were like you
got to prove you're doing something
you're not just watching netflix all day
long
and they wanted like written reports on
daily check-ins
and this group had more meetings while
working at home than they ever had in
the office
and and it caused a lot of issues and a
lot of employee morale really dropped
because they felt like
not they were being spied on but they
weren't trusted correctly
and so that new normal really is what
companies have been going to
for years right which is you know let's
use project management document
repositories
and collaborative environments for
companies doesn't matter where you're
located now the the second thing
is of course video i mean you can just
look at zoom stock price to know
how much video was used video chat was
used six months ago versus today
but when you look at human communication
again depending on what study
you want to listen to humans roughly
50 to 90 percent of all communication
is non-verbal right which means
a verbal is somewhere between 50 and 10
percent depending on his numbers you
listen to
and so you send an email there's no
context you have a phone call there's
you don't know
is are they happy are they mad what's
going on
so we solved this rise to video and
while this video this video rise
happened you would have you know sales
people still working of course right
they got new clients and stuff
and the normal didn't become pick up the
phone to talk on the phone or
you know or sometimes worse send an
entire team to a company's location
right they'd spend
you know three to five thousand dollars
in on pitching an agency
or pitching a new client their product
they just they hopped all hopped on
zoom google me teams whatever and and
suddenly
you could see what people's reactions
were
um you could have in-person meetings
from 3 000 miles away
and so the new normal from
a a pitch perspective right on boarding
a new client
is probably going to be a lot less in
person going forward
because if you can you know save three
thousand dollars not sending six people
to someone's office
to pitch who may not even win the pitch
um that that's
huge savings of course so we're really
seeing a difference in how companies are
pitching people
and this is carrying over to reporting
so
reporting's been kind of like that that
that sort of black box in the end
at times where you're an agency or
you're in-house and you send a report
off and say here's how we did last month
and maybe maybe you did a phone call to
talk the results
but again unless you're really clever
you don't know someone actually read
your report
you don't know why they were on the
phone but they're really just writing
email and you're just on speaker
talking away and they could care less
now again
with video you can see what they're
doing if someone's on a meeting over
here
you know writing an email and you can
tell they're paying no attention the
meeting
you know you can call them out right you
say hey let's do this some other time
and so we are seeing more
of the video used
right reporting pitch communication
now while this is is good in some ways
right you can now have that verbal if
it's every meeting
it's now the new term is video fatigue
right as opposed to decision making
fatigue of
i'm on video again i need to look nice
and smile and
you know because it's not a relaxed work
environment or you might you know kick
back in your chair a bit or this
um people feel more pressure in video
to you know look good and sound
eloquent in what they're doing as
opposed to a
an informal meeting right and their
office
and so the new norm is gonna find a
balance
of how much video should should we have
versus this is this is overkill
but it's also going to lead to
more video interaction with clients
as opposed to phone calls or email and
see almost a decrease in some email
times which is probably a welcome relief
for many people um you know tools like
slack of course anything collaboration
is definitely picking up so our new
normal
you know from what you're doing on a
daily basis isn't changing a lot you're
managing a google ads or seo account or
social or whatever
right that part doesn't change the way
you're interacting
with the team and sharing that and
collaboration
that's really what this new normal uh
more sits in
okay yeah and um when you talk about
zoom fatigue or video fatigue it's even
entered into the culture i mean we're
seeing
television commercials now that mock the
the zoom meeting and you know
the person over here who's using their
phone and the person over there
who doesn't know how to turn on audio
that type of thing um and i
it's interesting because so many new
people
so many people are you are new to the
platform of video conferencing
um people are used to facetime younger
people at least are used
to facetime but facetime is not
necessarily
a whole bunch of people at once um
and so it's it's interesting that we
changed over one one company
representative i heard speaking said
if they told us you have to figure out a
way to get everybody to work from home
um we would have said sure it'll take us
18 months and
20 million dollar investment and
they said and when it happened we were
able to do it instantly in three days
everybody was was on their home platform
so people yeah but not everyone did it
well
that's right and that's been kind of one
of the issues right
yeah and that touches on the point
you're making earlier is that
some people reacted to the loss of
face-to-face contact as a loss of
control
and put in pla systems that
like you said require many more meetings
and check-ins than they
had during the face-to-face office hours
um but we have found that you know as
things have settled out
um did a survey recently
where we found that most companies
report that
in fact productivity of work from home
workers
for them has increased so
they're they're very pleased with uh
with at least that
aspect of it if if not with uh you know
aspect of being able to do
the you know informal face-to-face
ad-hoc meetings
so and you know what so a trend just to
finish on that statement right
everyone especially those of you who are
thinking about you know job hunting and
stuff
so it's a trend that started a few years
ago was companies doing
some personality testing to to match
people up
so a lot of people like to say all right
apparently i'm a self-starter
right it's a common thing it's probably
so overwritten
but not everybody really is right not
everyone can sit down
at a computer with no one around and
just work
and there are people who are much better
in an office environment than they
are at a home environment um they're
just they work better they focus better
in
office work and so as
we're seeing people you know move some
back to office some remote
it we may see even more personality
testing by
companies saying like you just shouldn't
work remote which is not necessarily a
bad thing right
it's just some people are better um if
you're a big
extrovert man my extroverted friends are
are insane right now they just
they'll do anything to have over another
virtual coffee hour and i'm like enough
virtual drinks um right
and so there is a group who really is
better in office so i don't think we're
going to see
oh we're just a remote company that's
not going to work for everyone
so hybrid approaches we're seeing i
think we'll see a lot more hybrid things
as opposed to absolutes
yeah and that makes sense because uh
what will happen
under a hybrid approach is you'll be
able to reduce the density of the number
of people in the office
that you'll still allow a lot of people
to be working from home and
and the remote tools will let you
all integrate your work together as if
you're one big happy family
i hope you're able to see the next
question which is how can digital
marketers help their organizations
recover and reinvent themselves
following this pandemic
um so that's i mean before you answer it
and just to set that up
is we're we're all
in a different place than we expected to
be
um some of us paradoxically have found
the pandemic has increased business some
of us have found that the pandemic has
really destroyed the old business model
they had and
each person each department each member
of the team has to help
make that change and and
help the company recover so what's the
special responsibility of digital
marketers
you know i think one and you mentioned
analytics earlier
um is to reassess
all trends to see if they're still true
right so what we we've seen in the
pandemic right is of course
desktop and tablet search is up
considerably
and mobile is up a tiny bit but not as
much
um the commuter right that the nine to
five search curve
has leveled out a lot um weekend volume
is up
significantly crazy enough right and
um wheat day volume is barely changed
during this time um when we look at b2b
searches
they're they're more non-business hour
searches
right so a lot of the trends that we
just you know
just assumed that's true right we we
our people look for us nine to five when
they're in the office
um it's a travel thing so it's a weekend
search
they're gonna look on their phones first
and move to desktop
those have have completely shifted so
in country sorry mostly europe in this
case because us is not in a good
situation here but
we look at com countries who have you
know moved into their phase
and into three changes because there
are some hybrid work approaches right
you guys work from home
you be in the office i'm everyone's
going to stay working at home longer
we're just shutting down the office
whatever it is
some of those changes are not going back
to what they were
so so number one is just say here's all
the assumptions that we built our
marketing off of
do they still exist today or do we need
to shift some of
even how we used to do it because
it's a true new trend
the the second thing is we're gonna come
back to data yet again
um is there's been some
interesting creative uses of data
so a lot of companies say okay the
platforms let us do things like
geographic targeting and time of day
targeting in audience targeting and
and maybe if you're really creative
right you say
well we'll do inner city targeting
versus suburb target and change the
aging a little bit
but what the the national companies have
led and a lot of smaller ones
have followed is they've done
segmentation
based on phases
of recovery by location
so that if they're in lockdown
if your restaurant is delivery if
they're in in phase two
it's about contactless or it's contact
slavery
phase lockdown and then the next phase
it's about
eating outdoors or curbside pickup
versus eat inside right and so
by by looking at companies who sat there
and and there's charts now
there's nice charts that say here is the
different
phases by country location states
whatever
and they're using that to adjust their
messaging um in
not real time but but daily and so
as more data becomes available and we're
seeing companies thinking more
beyond the usual way they do targeting
um that's also going to be something to
look at post trend is
how is this how are our other creative
ways you can use your own data
or other trends in that targeting that
just didn't happen before um which which
is a great one but
really you know it's not about always
reinventing yourself right it's it's how
do we have to work
and how does the company want to work
and then it's saying all right based
upon these conditions
um what trends still continue
and what's new now and then third again
back to data what did
consumers do differently
that you expect them to continue
right during recovery so
if you're in um apparel right a lot of
companies have had that
take a picture upload it put on a new
shirt see how it looks on you with your
eyes or
you know stand in front of a mirror and
we're going to project
how a different dress looks or whatever
a lot of apparel creative stuff has
happened the last few years
but it's not been used much suddenly
right people really
are shopping shopping shopping at home
and there's no like i'm going to look
online then go to a store to try on this
this new this new shirt or dress or
whatever
and so if you've you know
seen on your site hey we have this
feature we
you know we implemented it two years ago
and it was no one was using it
are they now and is that something you
want to even invest
more in going forward of that virtual
way of doing business
another one is really thinking about
not just where you are in your business
recovery but your customers
right customers are they want data uh
much faster they want a lot more
transparency
so are there trends that started
virtual meetings right that should
continue
um and so it's it's not just about the
going back to what worked right it's
saying
what do we keep and then what have we
learned
and then obviously we're going to pull
you know what has changed that's going
to continue to to be different
and let's make sure we truly have those
things figured out first
then we know here's our new normal right
which is going to be an overused term
that everyone's going to hate very soon
um here's our new normal for desktop
tablet uh attribution funnels
um and use those going forward so
there's going to be a lot of
reassessments and changes that way so
really that's really digging into your
data your analytics customer changes
listening to customers
um a lot of that you know basically
marketing 101 right like
why your customers still doing business
with you
what changed their minds um from doing
business with someone else
and are your loyal customers still loyal
and if not
why what can you do and and some of that
you know surveying customers and things
like that it's going to be an important
thing again
yeah and that makes perfect sense
because we talk about
how the pandemic has driven a lot of
businesses to go
to a digital model and we talk about
we talk about that process as if it was
obvious as if it was driven by
the needs of production or operations
but
as you pointed out one good place to
start
there is to say well how do we have to
change the way we're marketing and
selling
and what things have been effective in
the past that we can continue to do
what things have we lost access to
and what are the new things that we have
to
adapt to because of of the
forced changes in the way we interact
yeah and this segways really well into
the next question which
you can put on the screen or i could
just read it for all that matters
because it's a good segue
um i believe we're at a poll
oh okay let's let's take a moment and
then we'll segue back into the next
question
perfect and um i will share
the poll question first visually
and what digital marketing skills
you currently use let me allow people to
answer that question
so the various digital marketing
specializations
which ones are you currently using in
your work
i always find mobile an interesting one
in here because some people just
consider mobile
part of seo and ppc and others pull
mobile out as its own channel
yeah it's always interesting when
everyone sort of treats mobile
differently as like
we don't do mobile we do paid search and
it shows up on on
you know devices yeah and i think one of
the distinctions there is whether
you have created an app that is
uh specific to that platform yeah
or sms we do see you know sms
increasing in usage email and social
media are the
the most used but it's uh
kind of across the board yeah i'm gonna
talk about the conversion one a little
bit
okay that number should be higher
so i'm going to go ahead and go to that
question we were about to segue into
so what are the challenges that digital
marketers
will face in this
postcode era so
where so when when you covet hit right
there are companies who
hit the pause button advertising
companies who
did nothing and let their advertising
run and
people who change their ads and
it's sort of important to think through
this really closely i mean the ads are
the message user sees
so when when you know companies even big
national companies hit pause and like
what's going on they would bring them
back and and so
initially right i did some comparisons
and i was looking at the insurance field
and
then it was very apparent who had
thought
this through one of the the the top ads
said um you know meet with us virtually
to get your insurance quote
the second one had just resumed their
old ads
and it was something like close the deal
with a handshake
now that was a that's a huge message
different right
of a handshake is one of those things
people like no
right that's exactly the opposite what
we should be doing and so
the the messaging is incredibly
important
and what's happening is messages are
becoming
common as marketers are are in in mass
going through
the changes and very similar ones so
early on right the messages were
we're in this together right and you saw
all the all these ads about
we're in this together we're here to
help and so forth
and it only took four to six
weeks until people were just tired of
this in fact after
i believe it was four weeks there was a
poll that's that said
how much do you like those and it was
something like 60
said we are done with them please stop
talking about we're in this together
right go
go back to anything else so so then the
the ads change right to
safety virtual curbside pickup
and some people did nothing and so
nothing sort of surprised me at times
about
um a month ago when it appeared
that we were going to see some big
shifts in august
um the cruise ship companies brought
back their old ads
and now the cruise ships of course they
they really made the media like we've
been out of
sea for eight weeks now and we can't get
off the boat and stuff
they brought back the old ads like
nothing happened
ignored this and and just wanted to be
oblivious to the whole thing
and of course that did not work well
right and so
we had um a client who does a high-end
appliance uh
sales you know you want a nice fridge or
dishwasher whatever
and they initially brought back their
old ads and and you know i was looking
at one day and talking on the phone and
i was like
you guys suggest i add a word you know
safe
in home delivery versus in-home delivery
and they're like what and i'm like just
just
try this them all right and it was
something
the next day um they had it's like a
seven percent
increase in conversion rate and a higher
increase in click-through rate
by putting safe and home delivery they
added five characters
and and you know the they own are coming
back and and you know we chat this
morning like
everyone should be doing this exercise
in the past
five months what did your business do
to change because of covid right did you
you sent employees home they work
virtually you're wiping down
certain packages now no one touches x
um you you you have made it so people
can come to the store by appointment
only um what have you done that's
different
tell users that but tell them tell them
in the ads tell them
on the website what's different they
they want to know what has changed
right and the amount of people early on
who are searching and look at an ad and
be like all right i just looked for a
restaurant
and you don't mention any of this stuff
so are you open and forgot you have ads
running
are you really letting us come in in and
dine which of course didn't happen for a
while
have you switched to delivery right and
so
users want fast up-to-date transparent
messages
right so as a marketer when you think
about business as usual it's
not business as usual right you're going
to have phases
of business changes
what did you do what do you need to
communicate to users
as a communi consumer
thought about what should be happening
changes
are you communicating readjusting those
messages and so
the speed of ad changes and updates
has not been this fast probably ever
um normally people make a tv commercial
they're really tough to make you make
them they last for you know anywhere
from six months to
five years um now we're seeing companies
switch commercials after a month of time
right they've just burnt out
here's the next one and that is really
on marketers
who especially digital ones who
sometimes uh
love the numbers but not always the
message the writing part
that this is super important and that
focus on messaging is one of the most
important things you can
do with the company to
think about business as usual um is
really
what is that consumer seeing from you i
mean that's a
a fascinating point because what
has changed in your business
see like you said so many companies
are ignoring that and and yet there are
some companies that are doing a
brilliant job of it
see they got to tell people that that
that's kind of the point right
if you do a brilliant job and don't tell
people you're not marketing it
that's what no that's what i meant is
they're doing a brilliant job of telling
um for example domino's pizza
makes a point of saying our pizza leaves
the oven at 450 degrees
it's untouched by human hands until it
gets to you
papa john's just came out with a safety
seal they're putting on right like you
kind of like you you open medication
bottles right and they get the seal
papa john's is putting the sticker now
on the outside pizza same thing like
same idea right
yeah even the car companies are saying
you know when we
when we prepare your car deliver your
car service your car
we're using um epa approved cleansers
and all of that to keep you safe so
um that that's a psychological
reassurance
that people need so that's a that's a
great point
um let me move to the to the next
question so what skills
should aspiring or current digital
marketers
that's everybody on this call
be adding to their repertoires to help
them be successful
in the future talk to you know what
you're doing now in your current job
but what are the things that people need
to do
differently and learn how to do
differently yeah
so going off the speed of message
changes
right is what we're starting to see and
it's still not as good as it should be
out there
is the the social team has always been
the best at reacting fast to things
um seo is the slowest to react to things
because they don't know how it's gonna
affect and
paid search is somewhere in the middle
right and so
because social is seeing the trends from
users
so quickly they are
collaborating more with paid search
and even organic and website observation
and so forth
on the message change and what people
need to know what they're caring about
but they can only do that if they
understand what each team
does right that that data sharing
is very important and so
you know i've always had this you know
idea right which has been a market
of concept for years of the the t-shape
marketer which is
we understand the basics of email social
paid search organic and so forth
so that as something changes you know
how to communicate it and
and collaborate cross channel right and
that's that
traffic driver part and then we have to
say all right
is this working right which is the
analytics part right which is saying
here's the new trend here's the data
trend what's actually working
and then we need to be able to test
those theories which is the conversion
optimization
uh piece and so
it's really good to be a specialist in
one
right you're great at paid search but
you understand the other pieces to have
those
collaborative conversations as we say
you know collaboration's been you know a
buzzword for years
it's really happening though with all
these video meetings and stuff going on
it's
many this has pushed a lot of companies
to
force collaboration where they ha they
are much more of a siloed place
and some of those those those walls are
falling down a bit um
but if but if you can't communicate with
them because you don't understand what
they do
it's not working well and so that's
really that
that first step right is understanding
what the whole team does
to collaborate better since you're using
the same tools
and move those things um secondly
with what's sort of interesting is
the the average consumer does not
study graphs and charts that often right
if if you're a stock broker yeah you're
constantly doing you're marketing your
analytics of course you're constantly
doing it
but there have been a ton of coveted
dashboards
right some are you look at them and
you're like i can't read the data at all
others you look at and go
that's a gorgeous dashboard and i can
glance at it and
understand everything and so these
the the the company owners writer like
you know what
you really can't communicate a lot with
a few
graphs i don't need your six pages of
reports
i really just need these three charts
and and so showing data visually
has been a touch of a concept for years
but it you know and some people are
excellent at it and expected others you
know don't care
um but because of all the the covet
dashboards
it's it's becoming more in demand to be
able to do
visual reporting and so you know
getting into hey here's how we can
really graph excel
or here is data studio and how we can
pull our data and data studio
and auto update these these wonderful
dashboards because
consumers are seeing a cover dashboard
updated daily
right and some marketers are like well
if they can do that for the whole
country in the world
why can't you do that for one account
which can easily be done with with the
data studio
or power bi whatever tableau
etc and so that's another really good
skill
is is data communication
which is you know more in excel and
stuff and then of course
any writing is going to be incredibly
important as well just communication is
such an important skill in general
but as people are not in
offices as much and don't have that
face-to-face non-verbal communication
because even video doesn't translate
every non-verbal um
then making sure they understand the
point is going to be incredibly
important
and those are probably some of the top
skills to really think of
if you've been studying digital
marketing for a while
then and you have a good basis think
really about
data visualization and and how you can
take that analytics data and other
things
and make it easy to interpret
that's an interesting point because you
know
marketing we always think of as you're
facing the customer or the prospective
customer and you're communicating to
those people but you're pointing out
that
facing the other direction towards your
co-workers your management your
company executives just as important
and learning the skills to to speak
their language
in a for or communicate the data in a
form that they can absorb
quickly and easily so they can deal with
you and then get to the
other pre you know 900 people they
manage
yeah i think they think of marketing
right
so so for those of you who are
especially some of the students here
right so
if you're a marketer then your job is to
convince people to
to deal with your company right that
that's quote what you're hired to do
but you have to prove you're doing a
good job
to your boss so they fund whatever
you they fund your paid search or
whatever and they keep you on the
payroll right i think
they want you employed so your
communication really is two-faced right
it's
it's not two-faced a bad thing right
it's it's consumers to say bye for me
and then the boss is saying hey look i'm
doing a good job so those internal
reports are incredibly important as well
that they understand what you're doing
so they're like hey you did a great job
here's more money to spend on paid
search or
you know here's your annual raise so
that internal communication is huge in
marketing
don't forget that aspect of it that
brings us
i think to last question
and i'm going to queue that up so
when we look at you know the situation
we're in it's like
i said a black swan so it's something no
one's ever seen before
and are there any specialized skills
that digital marketers can learn
now that will help organizations prepare
for similar situations in the future be
agile enough to
deal with something that comes out of
the blue and changes
you know i so there's a lot of ways to
kind of interpret this question
one i would encourage people to do
is learn a little about machine learning
um you don't have to write algorithms i
can't write a machine learning algorithm
i can't even read one
but i understand how it works and the
reason why
is it the past several years we've been
very much
a channel optimization with some
cross-channel
attribution but we're
entering what's sort of called a
predictive marketing era
so which means we're predicting
how things are going to sell or what
they're going to do
so we can adjust our marketing
beforehand now with the black swan
events this has really been been thrown
up in the air
in some cases but to give an example
right when you talk about predictive
marketing
like i can never do this there is a
company i've worked with for years
they sell electric fireplaces you know
if you if you want a fireplace in a home
that doesn't have a built-in fireplace
you can buy one plug it in you don't
have a fireplace right it seems like a
very simple product
now the first trend they saw was that a
forecast of snow increases conversion
rates
so you know they they know here's how
much fireplaces are installed by
household type
um by area of the country because
obviously
in the northeast us a lot of people have
built on fireplaces it's not common in
the south
so a forecast of snow in dallas means oh
it's a whole lot of stuff
a lot of sales we're going to make so
that was their first step
all right but but then they got to where
consumers are very you know demanding
and they realize that they need to be
able to ship within a day
now these are not small things so then
they started saying well let's look at
the the big weather forecast to say how
much snow is expected this
season by location to stock warehouses
predictively with data based upon this
right so we know
how much we need inventory management
now
if you if you well this is a story about
a fireplace company
there was a huge spike in searches in
february
for mass hand sanitizer and webcams
no one did predictive inventory
for those three items which meant in
march
there was none of the three available
now think if
logitech would have noticed there's a
eight thousand percent increase on
people searching for
webcams and shifted their factories
immediately to produce webcams as
opposed to new mice
they would have sold a tremendous amount
of inventory
right again using your data predictively
so
so then right the the the electric
companies electric fireplace company
said all right most of forecasts we get
are accurate at three days but there is
some
10-day forecast that's kind of accurate
and and so they started using multiple
forecasts to build their
own models 10 days in advance
so they could change their messages a
week in advance and so demand for their
fireplaces would go up
multiple days before the snow event when
people wanted these
right and that's predicting data and you
don't have to understand machine
learning algorithms
to start seeing that type of a trend
to know how to work it right to to focus
on that
but if you don't know how any machine
learning works then it
really is truly black box when you go
turn on google cpa bid you're like
we don't know what events are going to
affect this um
and so any of that is going to be an
incredibly
useful skill second
is you know if you're a good marketer
right you've taken marketing classes
you've done some marketing
is how was this being executed in
companies
and so the other one is a trend towards
agile marketing so
agile project management has been around
for several years where
you you break up the projects being done
into short tasks you put sprints
together
to really focus on getting things done
and and
companies who do a lot of software
development um
some of them have moved to this this
type and then
scott brinker uh several years ago sort
of applied this to it to marketing
now in the era of code right
these events that are fastly changing
things
if you're a waterfall type of a project
company meaning
we have an idea we toss it over to
uh design they come up with some designs
we
pass it to legal it goes from legal over
to
brand or whoever it comes back to us
four months have passed
and the events is completely different
now um
it's very hard to do stuff so
understanding agile project management
and being able to help your company
implement that
so while you may not use it all the time
when you have these events
you can quickly shift and get it done
because everyone's
understands and and someone can manage
how that changes
and so that's gonna be another really
useful skill is working in
agile marketing along with just
understanding machine learning
and of course how marketing works in
general uh digitally
thanks that's great advice um two things
that don't sound like they're related
but they are
definitely related to being able to
to respond rapidly to this kind of
said black swan of them so i guess we're
at the point of the
presentation where we can recap what
we've talked about
give you a a minute or two to do that
so you want me to recap what we've gone
through oh there we go there's our recap
right awesome out of our conversation
what are the things you'd like people to
take away
you know so in reality
right you a have to understand how
the basics of all the marketing the
social the email the
so forth so you see how they they fit
together
two right listen to customers which i
know that that's not new marketing
advice it's but it's evergreen advice
and then listen to them and then tell
them
what you're doing as a company there's
such a speed now
and a transparency users that you
really need that corporate voice to to
talk to them
about what's going on and so don't
forget
that message right what do they need to
know what are they hearing
and then as we see
new normal i hate the term but we're
going to use it from in this context
as you kind of go back to normal think
about
visualizing data think about how you
can better collaborate internally
um with everyone which some of it
started
um i i fear in some companies that don't
forget everything they've learned and go
back to old habits which hopefully
they don't if they've you know done some
digital transformation
in the past few months um keep
up with changes things are moving very
quickly right now they're going to keep
moving quickly for probably the next six
months could be a year hopefully not
um so you want to watch that but in the
end
it's about how you talk to users
marketing is about convincing
people to do business with you right
it's the art of persuasion is what
marketing is
um and so
what are you talking to users and what
are you talking
with them the conversations they're
having is incredibly important
right everything else is targeting how
they see it when they see it
right the message is is what's super
important never forget that
and the evolution of all the changes
what's the end message everything else
is
how the delivery system it's not the
message itself
um but then don't forget of course the
math and the and the analytics behind it
tells everyone in your company why
you're doing a great job and you should
be employed they should give you more
money
right which is always a nice thing in
the end i think it's time for us to do
the last pull that really gets back to
what we've just been talking about which
is
what are the new skills that you'd like
to learn same set of skills but
in this case which ones are you not
using now that you want to learn
how to use yeah so you know why this
poll is up right in reality you've got a
traffic driver
seo paid search email mobile social
they're traffic drivers they get traffic
to the site
and those teams well it's good to be a
specialist right in one of them those
teams collaborate together should know
how things work
then you have analytics for saying how
good of a job did we do
right analytics informs everyone are you
doing a good job
what are the trends you should be
looking for then you take that and you
say we need
better conversions right which is your
your website conversion optimization
which makes the changes that gets pushed
up to the traffic drivers
which then gets read by the analytics
right they're all interrelated
so understanding the basics of all of
them let you
talk to everyone correctly and then
specializing in one
is like saying i love website conversion
and therefore i'm going to focus on
conversion rates but
i need to be able to tell the ppc people
the seo people
why they need to do this and why they
implement changes but i have to
speak to them in their language to do
that well the analytics person needs to
be able to say
here's the analytics data we're seeing
and how it relates back
to what you do so having that basics
of everything in this specialization
makes for really good
internal collaboration and work and just
better marketing for the company
yeah and related to to you know your
example of i love
website conversion but i need to be able
to tell ppc what i need
we also need to understand ppc's
language so that when they come to you
and say this is what we want to do
and this is how our website should field
it that you understand
you know what they're asking everyone
needs to speak the same language
that's really where you got to start
right everybody's interested
in a little bit of everything the
website conversion went up from who's
doing it
yeah now that's good
so gotta convert the traffic
so we've reached our q a portion of our
area and we've got a number of questions
from the audience and i'm gonna
go ahead and ask a few of those
so how do you know when you have to
change your ad message
that's one question you know it's so
a your data starts spiraling downwards
right so suddenly your conversion rate's
dropping and click through rates
dropping so forth
two you're monitoring competitors
and they've changed their ads and you
need to respond
to it or three
because someone else in your department
said hey we're making this change
internally and right and that's your
communication to users
usually the changes drive from one of
those three areas which is
you know why we talk about messages so
much okay
um we have an entrepreneur who has an
ai-based startup company and they're
wondering
how digital marketing can help grow the
business in the pandemic environment
oh sure i mean that's that's such an
open-ended question
um it doesn't matter what business type
you are right
in reality digital marketing is about
saying who
needs to hear our message right so
that's your targeting aspect of
first figuring out what's my customer
profile who are they are they searching
are they
on social where are they right and then
what message should we communicate to
them
to have them want to do business with us
or initially it may be
hey we exist and you should know about
us right
then later on like all right now that
you've you saw who we are
you've done some more research now it's
time for you to go you know
be a client do a demo whatever the next
step is um so that's just
looking through your funnel you know
what are the funnel steps you need to go
through
who's your ideal customer and then
laying up the targeting the message for
each of those steps which you can do
with all the all the different types
there's definitely been an increase in
search behavior over
um email and in in programmatic in the
past
four or five months um well everything
is increased as search has actually
increased higher
than the others also i'd
say in response to this question the
things that you talked about during the
presentation about the
importance of understanding ai and how
ai
can contribute to businesses as
a specific angle that this questioner
should
maybe listen to the recording again and
pull some of those points into their
marketing um do you think the new trend
of using
productivity tracking software for
monitoring remote workers is going to
apply
even more pressure digital marketers
uh yeah i mean so
i struggle with this one personally
right because
i want to trust employees to go do the
right thing
and and i'm an outcome-based person if i
if these are the tasks
that you're assigned to as long as you
do a good job i really don't
care if it took you five hours or 15
hours right i mean i'm
what was it a good outcome but again
when we had
offices it's been a long time spent
offices i used to also tell people when
you're done with work
go home don't sit around doing nothing
right people sometimes sit there for two
hours doing nothing and they're just
bored right but if you have work to do
stay late right and
and that's um that's important but when
you get to companies of 10 000
20 000 people they don't trust other
employees that way
and so tracking when people are tracked
they feel more pressure and so i fear
some of the tracking software is going
to make
people dislike their jobs at times
and feel more pressure to do more than
maybe what's necessary
especially where you're more concerned
with the volume of work than as opposed
to quality
and that's something that could
definitely suffer with that um
i get it's necessary and you know at
some point maybe you just need to
monitor how often the vpn is being used
and not every little thing they're doing
to
have employees feel there's some freedom
in involved still
but that's gonna be it's a much bigger
question that's going to be a question
hr struggles with for a while um after
how they do it so the company gets what
they need
but employees feel the
in that that company is is not spying on
them and you know force them to go
work right but that they're um
collaborating with their own company
and they're they're making things
prosper as opposed to spying on
on them and the last question
for you have any best practices in ppc
changed because of this pandemic and
what the
best practices themselves
have not necessarily changed what has
changed is the speed of
implementing changes so you know it's
best practice to have good ad group
organization right so that way
these keywords these ads go together
things things things work out well
and and but the problem with that right
is if you don't know say the patriots
really well
you've got 10 000 ad groups and suddenly
you need to change 10 000 ads
someone who has that has a good working
knowledge
of paid search can make that change in a
couple minutes
um someone who has an average working
knowledge may look at that as like an
all-day task suddenly and it's
overwhelming so
the need to have best practices but also
really understanding the intricacies of
the engines for
making sweeping changes is probably more
important now than it has been
in quite a while um i do have one last
question that came in
um and it's an interesting one which is
more effective in your opinion seo or
sem
it's it's not the right question um i
know a lot people love this question seo
versus ppc right
they're very different they're
complementary
so there have been many many studies
done that says
right if you're only in organic you miss
this percentage of
people of customers if you're only in
paid you miss this percentage if you're
in both the numbers aren't additive
they're actually they're higher because
there's this halo effect
of being in both simultaneously um
where where people sometimes wonder well
we ranked number one for our brain term
why should you buy the ads
because your brand term always goes to
your home page so do you want people on
your email list right use the brand but
but direct it you can change the
messages very fast
so there are different marketing
channels that happen to show up on the
same
page um but they're complementary
they're not they're not uh they don't
fight each other
they're they're used together okay
that's
great that's all the questions we have i
want to say thank you to brad
for joining us today um hey and thanks
stuart for hosting us and keeping
conversation going
um how can people keep in touch with you
we have the twitter uh
handle up are there other channels or is
that the best way
um i mean i'm all over linkedin to
linkedin twitter
best two places usually i mean you can
come to our website at alices.com
um any of the above i'm pretty you
search for me you'll find me
okay great um we do have
uh the step into the sunlight series
continuing
next two tuesdays are scheduled for a
project management discussion with tim
jerome
and uh that's july 7th july 14th
cloud computing and devops a very
important topic
with uh matthew david yeah is tim going
to get into agile project management
i believe that's correct yes so that's
what we talked about today too so that's
a good one for everyone here to go
go watch exactly he's a great speaker
and um we invite everyone to connect
with simply learn we are also
on linkedin twitter and facebook
and we thank you for being with us today
this is the end of our our presentation
uh we will be sending out
certificates of proof of attendance to
people
who have stayed with us thus far like to
invite everybody to
go ahead and log off now and to end the
presentation thanks again
you